all right before we start the shyness
wanna send some love out to all our
troops fighting all over the world for
freedom right now
that's right let's send it out to the
Troops now
our first presenter is an Academy Award
winner for a role in monsters ball and
will next be seen in the eagerly awaited
Catwoman - give it up for Halle Berry
77 years ago the first Oscar was cast it
was originated with a sketch by the
legendary art director Cedric Gibbons
tonight it is my honor to cast the first
Oscar of the evening for achievement in
art direction please join me in
welcoming this year's wonderful nominees
in the Aviator the colorful life of
Howard Hughes was the inspiration for
the art direction of Dante Ferretti and
the set decoration our Francesca was
shop
in finding Everland the story behind the
creation of Peter Pan was portrayed in
the art direction of Gemma Jackson and
the set decoration of Tricia Edwards the
film Lemony Snicket's A Series of
Unfortunate Events has brought nothing
but good fortune to art director Ric
Heinrichs and set decorator Cheryl
caressing the stage version of Andrew
Lloyd Webber's The Phantom of the Opera
was spirited on to the silver screen
with the art direction of Anthony Pratt
and the set decoration of Celia Boehm
in a very long engagement with art
direction of Aleen Veneto swept us
through a passionate story of love and
lost set in France during World War one
and the Oscar goes to Dante Ferretti for
The Aviator decoration friendships
killer shava
this is the eighth nomination for Dante
Ferretti and six for Francesca Rishabha
tonight they win their first Academy
Award good evening ah thank you for this
great honor tonight to be here thank you
to the Academy I would like to say thank
you first of all to Marty Scorsese great
great great director which we love very
very much and I want to say thank you to
all the producer to Graham King Michael
Mann to RV Weston and the old entire our
department which without them it was
impossible for me to do this food for
for us thank you just I'd like to say
this Oscar is for Melissa
Eduardo Oh George Oh
this next actress has incredible range
she put on 25 pounds to play Bridget
Jones and this year she's putting on 80
pounds to play Deacon Jones please
welcome please welcome the Academy Award
winner Renee Zellweger